want to make a discord bot that talks
like characters from rick and morty or
harry potter
maybe you want to make it talk like
another favorite character in this
course lynn will show you how to create
a discord bot that uses artificial
intelligence to talk like a character of
your choice
hi there i'm ling i'm a software
engineer hobbyist game developer and
recent graduate from the university of
chicago
in this tutorial we're going to build a
discord ai chatbot that can speak like
your favorite character
before we start if you have seen that
video by any chance know that this video
is something different and more
comprehensive so keep watching to the
end the original tutorial and my first
discord bot started as a joke between me
and my friends when we were playing
video games and it really surprised me
how popular it became and a lot of
people wanted to build their own bot
based on that tutorial
therefore i decided to update that
tutorial to include more characters as
well as to show you how to find data for
your favorite character
other topics that we will cover here
include but are not limited to how to
train the model how to deploy the model
common errors you might see during this
model training and deployment pipeline
and how to solve them
moreover we will cover how to build the
bot in python and how to build it in
javascript
lastly we will cover how to properly
deploy the bot to a discord server and
limit it to certain channels
and how to keep the bot running
indefinitely
i hope you're excited and let's jump
into the tutorial
first we are going to find data for our
character
my favorite sources are kaggle
transcript wiki and just random fandom
websites that came out from the google
search and my research process goes like
this i first search on kaggle to see if
there are pre-made dialogue data set
for example
if we search for rick and morty
we get this nicely formatted data set
that includes the name of the character
and the liner speaking
if we search for harry potter
here is another data set that includes
the character and the sentence they're
speaking
since we're building a chat bot we need
only these two columns in our data set
the character name and the line they're
speaking so these dialog data sets on
kaggle are perfect for our requirement
all right if we succeeded in finding out
data on kaggle we can move on to the
model training step
but what if we cannot find a data set
for our character on kaggle for example
if i want to find a data set for peppa
pig
it looks like there is no data set for
the character
in this case we may need to find the raw
transcript of the media be it a video
game a cartoon on a show
and i found that transcript wiki has
some great resources
so here we have a list of movies shows
video games musicals commercials
for example i was able to find a
transcript for peppa pig and also movies
like batman on transcript wiki
the transcript looks like this
so we have the character name and their
actions or the lines they're speaking
we will see shortly
how to turn a raw transcript like this
into a data set like those we saw on
kaggle
besides transcript wiki you may also
just google the name of your media with
the keyword transcript
for example my first spot was based on
the game the word ends with you
and it has no results either on kaggle
or transcript wiki so what i did was to
just google the name of the game
and game transcript
and it just happened that this fandom
website has
the full game transcript
so be sure to utilize your google search
skills to find data for your character
if rather than fictional character you
are more interested in real life
character you may search for interview
scripts as your data source
if you want to create a chat bot that
speaks like yourself or your friends you
can treat text messages between you and
your friends as dialogues and handcraft
your data set
there are tons of ways to get data for
your character so be creative
and now we will look at how to turn raw
transcript into data set
now suppose we have found our raw
transcript let's see how we can turn it
into a two column character line data
set
suppose we take this peppa pig
transcripts and copy them into a text
file
now we go to google collab and upload
our data file
then we create a google colab notebook
and use this to parse our script
so i'm going to name this parse script
dot ipymb
and we are going to from
google collab
import
drive
and then call drive dot mount
content
drive
this will allow us to read the data from
our google drive
all right now that our drive has been
mounted let's import os
and then
os
change
directory into
content
drive
my drive
and now we see if there is anything in
it
yeah we have our peppa pig.txt
so here we are going to import regular
expression to parse over transcript put
the parsed result into the pandas
dataframe and export it as a csv file
just like those we saw on kaggle
this is going to be our regular
expression pattern
you don't have to be a pro irregular
expression to understand this part
if we take the pattern
to the site
and our test string is
peppa pig
you will see that we have two matched
capture groups the first being the
character's name the second being the
line spoken and also for the second line
mama pig we have
the character name and the line being
spoken
great so that's our regular expression
now let's define a dictionary that will
store our data
so we know that we need the column name
and the column line in our result data
frame
and then we open and read the file
for each line we match it with our
regular expression pattern
if there is a match
we extract name and line from this
regular expression
match
and then
append it to our dictionary here
and then we convert this dictionary into
a data frame
now we can inspect the data frame
quote so we have the name is peppa pig
saying that i'm peppa pig and then
george makes the sound that mama pig
makes a sound
great
we can also count the number of lines
that belong to our character
so we do some
df
name
is equal to
peppa pig
and we saw that peppa pig has
38
lines in our entire data frame
so the length of our data frame is over
100 and peppa pig has one third of the
lines
great the last step will be to export
the data frame so df.2 csv
the name will be perfect
csv
and
and we will drop the index
cool
now we should have a peppa pig.csv in
overdrive
and here it is
name and line
this is how we parse those raw
transcript into a file that could be
used in our model training so next let's
proceed on to the exciting step model
training
now we are going to train the model
go to my github repository linked to in
the description below and download the
content
we are going to use this
model train upload
workflow.ipymb which looks like this
all right now our file has been
downloaded we unzip the content
and in here we have a model training
upload workflow.ipym
we upload this notebook file to google
drive and open it in google collab
we are going to train a gpt model which
is short for generative pre-trained
transformer
in the runtime change runtime type make
sure to select gpu because this will
accelerate our model training
so now here we mount the drive
we install the transformers module that
we'll be using
and we change directory into my drive
here are all the modules that we are
importing
if we're using the data set from kaggle
we need to obtain our api key from
kaggle
so go to our kaggle profile go to
account
scroll down to the api key section
create a new api token and download this
file as cargo.json
we'll go back to google drive and upload
cargo.json
now we can download our data set from
kaggle we're going to use the harry
potter dataset as an example
so grab this username and the dataset
name
and our file is harrypart1.csv
note that because there are white spaces
in our file name we got special
characters in the file name so let's
inspect the content of our
data file
well csv files are usually separated by
commas has the name csv however this one
looks like it's separated by
semicolons
so we need to take care of the
semicolons when we are reading the data
into a pandas data frame so separation
is
semicolon instead of a comma
cool so let's sample our data to see
what's inside
all right so we have character and
sentence
notice that
these two column names aren't exactly
what we need
we want the two columns of our data
frame to be named as
name
and
line
as used down here in this cell so we
need to change the name of our columns
all right let's resample our data
looks like we have successfully changed
the name of our columns
now let's see how big our data is
so it only has a thousand or so lines
and let's see
how many lines our character has
our character has 155 lines
so here we change our character name to
harry
and we now run this cell to create a
context data frame that includes the
current line our character is speaking
and several lines directly proceeding
the line
a context data frame is useful here
because we are creating a conversational
chatbot
and we want to generate a response based
on the conversation context
so let's sample our context data frame
so in the context of clearly something
something our character responds
with seems to pity not to ask her
great now we have our data set we split
the data set into a training set and a
test set
this is because we don't want to overfit
the model in the case of overfitting the
model will just memorize lines from the
data set and talk back to us using the
exact lines we don't want that we want
the conversation to be more organic
so we're only training the model on the
training set and evaluating the model on
the test set
so we continue running these cells
to build data sets caching checkpoints
and down here we built the model
we will build our model by fine-tuning
microsoft's
pre-trained gpt small
small here refers to the number of
parameters in the model
there are also a median and a large
model generally the larger the model the
longer it takes to train but the smarter
the model can get
i would recommend training a medium
model as it's pretty smart and not too
hard to train
my production chatbot that is currently
running on a server with a thousand plus
users is also a medium model
for this tutorial for the sake of time
i'm training just a small model
you can see here it's downloading the
model and this may take some time
because it's essentially 300 megabytes
here are some hyper parameters that you
may find useful
for example
num train epochs is the number of
training epochs this is defined to be
four here and this is the number of
times that the model will cycle through
the training set
as long as the model is not overfitting
increasing the number of training epochs
usually results in smarter models
because the model has more time to cycle
through the data set and pick up the
nitty-gritty details
there's another hyper parameter called
batch size
this is the number of training examples
that the model will see in the batch
before it updates its gradient i
wouldn't recommend changing this unless
you know what you're doing
since other hyper parameters like
learning rate and temperature might be
sensitive to this change in batch size
however if you're training a larger
model on a larger data set and are
running into memory errors to make the
error go away it might help to decrease
the batch size
the remaining cells have been configured
to take in this context data frame we
created train the model and save it to a
folder called
output small
now let's run this main function
training will take some time i trained
my medium model for 12 epochs and it
took around 2 hours so do sit back and
grab a snack while the model is training
you can see the progress in the progress
bars
above right here we get back a
perplexing tensor this usually refers to
how confused the model is
if a model has a large complexity it
means that the model is pretty confused
as to which words to choose to respond
to a given situation and the model might
not be very smart in our case our data
set is pretty small it only has 150 plus
lines so
it makes sense that the perplexity is
high to decrease the perplexity we might
need to train for more epochs
cool but now that the training is
complete we can load and chat with the
model here
right let's change the name of the box
hello
fellow red rider
so let's ask
pause
quidditch
there is no such thing as a bad
red rider
great it looks like our chat bot is
capable of making and maintaining a
conversation
now we can push the model to hugging
face and start building our discord
chatbot
all right now let's change directory
just into the content folder
because we'll be doing a push there
and we do pip install hugging face
command line client
and then we log in using our credentials
all right after logging we're assigned
this token we need to grab this token
for the cell that we need to do
afterwards
so we can create a repository to store
our model from the command line
mine is going to be called dialog gpt
small harry potter
and our empty model repository is right
here
there is nothing except for the git
attributes file but we will be adding in
the model files soon
now we install git lfs which stands for
git large file storage this will allow
us to push and pull all models
and we replace this token with the token
we just copied from above
so here is my username and my token
and recall that our training result is
stored in this output small directory
and then we change directory into our
dialog gpd smart directory because we
need to do git
add and commit from there
we install the get lfs
and inspect the content to our current
directory which should be dialog gpt's
small harry potter
and also just
print out the working directory we are
in to make sure that we are inside
content
cool
now we check the file status on git
so these files not we need to add to get
so we do a git add this will take some
time because the pi torch model dot
being is pretty large
and we configured a global username and
user email these are just my huge face
credentials
and we commit with message initial
commit
and finally we push the model
it's about 400 megabytes because the pi
torch model is itself about 400
megabytes
all right looks like the push is
complete
now we see our pi torch model here
however there is one more thing that we
need to do before we can converse with
the model on hugging face that is you
see here it's tagged as text generation
however we know that we are training a
chatbot model and we want our model to
be conversational
for that purpose we need to edit a model
card
so we create a model card here
and we put in our desired model text so
our tags
is
conversational
and we commit our
model card
and
now our model is correctly tagged as
conversational
if we go to the main model page
we can start chatting with the model
here
change
all right now that we have
pushed our model to hugging face we're
ready to use it in our discord chat box
now we have our model let's build the
discord bot
here on discord i have my server links
developed i have two channels
one for the python bot and one for the
javascript bot
the reason why we have separate channel
for the box is because we don't want the
bots to be talking to each other
so after we build the bot we will learn
how to set their permissions correctly
so that they don't go outside of their
dedicated channel
so we go to discord developers page
create an application
we need one application per bot
so our name will be chat about
python
so here we create a bot
and i'm going to name this
harry potter
bot
python
and upload an icon
we will be using this api token here
when we create our bot in python
we're going to host our bot on repo it
so sign up for reproductive and create a
new python repo here
i'm going to name those
chatty
chattybot
python
and in here we will need to store our
api tokens for hugging phase and discord
as environmental variables
so here is a tab for the secrets
for the environment variables
so the first one will be
plugging face
token
and for the value we will go to our huge
face profile
add a profile
api tokens
copy the api token
come back here
and fill in that value
next we'll create a discord token
[Applause]
and for this value
we go to this discord developers portal
and copy the token
we add the token here
and our environment variables are all
set
next i have the python file in my github
repository called discord.py
so we grab the code from here and i'll
explain the code line by line
starting from line 1 we first import the
os module that will help us reading our
environment variables
next we import modules that are useful
for quarry in the hacking phase model
finally we import the discord module and
here i have my api url pointing to my
username
and we define about as follows
in the init function
it takes in a model name
which for me will be
dialog gpt small harry potter
then we store this api endpoint
by concatenating this api url which is
my profile link with the model name
then we retrieve the secret api token
from the system environment
by looking up os.environment huge phase
token
next we format the header in our request
to hoggyface for the authorization part
we put in barrier and the hugging phase
token
next we define a query method that takes
in the payload
we dump the payload as a json string
and use the request module to make an
http post request
to the api endpoint using our defined
request headers which contains our huge
face api key
and passing the data
once the request finishes it should give
us a response object and we decode
it
from utf-8
and load
the result as a string and return the
string next we define an asynchronous
function
named already
the next two function definitions are
based on the discord api
both are asynchronous function the first
one is already
this function will be called when the
bot is logging in
so when the bot is logging in we will
print out logged in as
out the box name and the box id
so that we know that the bot is
functioning
next because our bot is a chat bot it
needs to respond to messages so all
message is a method that will be called
each time the bot sees a message in the
channel
so given the message
if
the message is coming from the bot
itself
the bot ignores the message and does not
reply to it
otherwise it will form a query payload
with the content of the message
and to make the bot more user-friendly
while the bot is waiting for the hdb
response from the model we set its
status as typing so that the user will
know that the bot is generating its
response
so this is a synchronous call with
message.channel.typing
we call soft.query using the payload and
get back the response
if there is a valid generated response
there will be a generated tax field in
this response
and will be able to get that out as the
bot's response
otherwise there might be an error in the
response we just log out the error
message so that we can debug the bot
later on
finally we use another asynchronous
method to send the box response to the
channel using message.channel.send
and that's it about our bot definition
in the main function
we just create a bot and pass in the
model name so for me this is style of
gpt small
harry potter
and
use client.run
looking up
the discord token from the environment
variables
great now that our bot should be all set
up let's invite the bot to our channel
in the off 2 tab
we are going to select the bot
and for the bot permissions
the only thing in need is to send
messages
so we copy this url
paste it in a new browser window
and invite it to my server
all right now that we see that our bot
has appeared however it shows us offline
so we need to run the repo
so we hit run
here and repo.it is installing all our
dependencies and imports
great now that our bot has logged in as
harry potter about python and this is
its unique id
let's go to the server and now that the
bot is online
i don't want the bot to appear in the
general channel so
we go to the channel setting
permissions
advanced permissions
add
the bot
and we remove its
permission to send messages
and save the changes
now
let's see what happens if i type
something in the general channel nothing
should happen because the bot shouldn't
be able to send a message
nothing happens although the bot is
online
and
now the spot should work in this python
box channel so let's do hello
and we briefly saw that there is a
typing
prompt
[Applause]
cool
so yeah this is how we built a bot in
python
one thing to know in our repo it is that
because we
took away the bot's permission to send
the messages in the general channel
it is showing an exception and this is
totally okay
if you don't like seeing this exception
you can use a try except block and lock
out this exception
great so now we're going to repeat the
process for the javascript bond
so we go back to the discord developer
portal
and create new application this time i'm
going to call it chat about
javascript
and we create a bot
back to repo it
we create a node.js app
going to call it chatty.js
we again create two environmental
variables
the first one is hugging
face
token
copying my api token from my profile
added profile
putting here
and copy my discord bot token
call this one discord
token
and adding the value
great now we have our environment
variables set up
go to my github repository there is a
desktop.js file that contains the code
that we will use for this javascript
chatbot
let's copy paste
and i'll go through the code line by
line
so first we import the discord say api
for the javascript module
and
we import fetch for making http requests
just like we did in python
and we initialize a new discord client
and define the model url
just as
my username and the model name so this
guy is
dialog gpt small
harry potter
and
this is the same callback that is called
when the bot is ready just like the on
ready function we saw in python
so when the bot is ready and logged in
we print out login as client user.tag
and here is another callback this time
on message we use an asynchronous
callback
because
we are making http requests
like in the python script we ignore the
message if the message is from the bot
itself
by checking if message dot author is the
bot
now we form the payload
so the payload is a dictionary
containing input
with text message.content which is the
message that the bot has received
and we form the request headers
by again using the hugging face api key
so we read the hugging phase token from
the environment
process.aim the hugging face token
and form the headers
right before we start making the http
request we set the bot status to typing
now record the server
so the response is the result from this
call to fetch using http post
given the payload as the body and
the headers using the huge phase token
and
we convert the response into json format
and extract out the generated text field
if there isn't a generated text field in
the response but instead the response
contains an error field this means that
the bot has encountered some errors and
we may want to print out the error for
further debugging
now that we have the box response we can
clear out its typing status and send the
message to the channel as a reply
this ends the definition
of our client dot all message call
down here we log in using the discord
token
now let's invite the bot to our server
so we go to all auth
check the bot
its only permission is to send messages
we copy this
paste in
a new browser window
and invite it to our server
great looks like we have another bot
remember to click on save changes
otherwise the box icon wouldn't be
showing
now that we have our bot however it's
not logged in
so we need to go back to the repo to run
our script
but before we run our repo let's make
sure that the bot doesn't have access to
the general channel
nor does it have access to python
channel because it's not supposed to go
there
so in permissions
we find this chat about javascript
remove its permission to send messages
and always remember to sync the changes
we do the same thing for it on the
python channel
and go to the js channel
this time
the one we need to remove
is the python bot
so this python box shouldn't be able to
send messages to this javascript channel
now we go back to run our repo dot it
if you see this error
this means that the discord version that
npm is trying to install is wrong you
can see that there are those warnings
that the newest discord
module is not compatible with
repo.its version of node or npm so we
need to manually change something in
package.json
so here
we just use the
older version
and rerun it
now that we are logged in as chat about
javascript
1048
let's go back to our discord channel
cool the chat about is also online let's
see if it responds to our messages
alright so this is now an error message
telling us that the model is still
loading the model will usually take one
or two minutes to load so let's give it
some time
great looks like our bot is responding
to us
and because we have set the bot's
permissions correctly the python bot is
not responding to any messages here and
the javascript bot shouldn't be able to
talk here
and in our general channel
no bot is ever allowed to talk here
cool so now we have successfully built
the bot both in python and in javascript
one thing to note is that
if i close the browser tab
for the python bot
the bot is no longer responding although
it still shows that the bot is online
so in the next part we're going to look
at how to keep the bot running
indefinitely in the browser even when we
close the browser tab
in order to get our bot to run
indefinitely we need to create a web
server in repo.net and set up a
service called uptime robot to
continuously ping the web server
so this is for the python bot and we
create a new file
called keepalive.py
and we add the code for
a web server
like this
and in our main.py we import that part
and down here in the main function right
before the bot runs
we ask it to be kept alive
and we run it
when the code runs we see
a url shown in this tab
and we copy this url and bring it to our
uptime robot service
so here is the uptime robots website and
i already have an account so i'll just
go to my dashboard and add a new monitor
monitor type is going to be https
friendly name discord
python bot
the url
is the one we copied from here
and the monetary level
will be a pin every five minutes that
should be sufficient
and finally we create monitor
and close it
now let's see if our python bot is
capable of running indefinitely
all right i'm going to close this tab
containing my python script
and
it looks like our model is still up it's
just that after some time the model on
hugging face back end will reload but
because the bot itself is responding we
know that
our web server approach has worked
now let's repeat this process for the
javascript bot
we create a new file called server.js
and copy paste
these code
then
we import
this part from the file that we just
created
finally right before the bot runs
we are going to call keep alive
stop the service
and run it
all right the server is now ready
we copy this url
go to uptime robot
and add a new monitor
it's again an http monitor
this cord
jsbot
and the url is like this
and we create a monitor
now we can safely close this browser
window and go back to our discord chat
and the bot is still ready
great now we're all done we have a cool
python chatbot and a cool javascript
chatbot that can run indefinitely
i hope you enjoyed this video please
subscribe for more content like this and
i'll see you in the next one